[Music]
this is a story about airplane food I
know what you're thinking but this isn't
just any airplane food this is the creme
de la creme the cream of the crop the
icing on the cake
all around the world thousands of
business and first-class passengers get
to enjoy the decadent and delicious
gourmet recipes of none other than chef
Matt and his trusty team let's see how a
meal takes off we're here at one of gay
gourmet kitchens where airline food is
prepared I am chef Matt and these are
some of our teams we have soar room
culinary production and transportation
across our three kitchens in Atlanta we
serve 180 thousand meals a week to put
in perspective we use 30 million slices
of cheese a year in the u.s. along with
85 tons of spinach eight million
strawberries and 25 million bread rolls
delivery trucks will arrive and items
will be temperature checked and then
those items will be moved to their
respective area it'll be prepped and
cooked those items are then packed into
the airline foils and boarded on to the
carts that are then pushed onto our
trucks and delivered to the aircraft
[Music]
the cabins have less moisture like we do
on the ground you need moisture in order
to get full flavor the full taste of
food so we designed to really combat
that in the air so you're finding a lot
more items that are highly seasoned we
really like to highlight those items so
that the food tastes the same down on
the ground that it does up in the air
hot smoked salmon polka with mango and
edamame buffalo milk burrata with some
cucumber ribbons and some balsamic
pearls a pan-seared sea bass with a
fennel puree pumpkin tortelloni finished
with Osan Charles no desserts I only eat
them when designing meals I really look
for a couple key factors and that the
food is using lots of fresh acids and
herbs to really enhance the passenger
experience onboard I think I'm very
fortunate that the food that I design
whether someone's going on vacation or
traveling for business is the first
taste that they have on their new
adventure and I think it'd be more
fortunate that it's the last taste that
they have before they come home
[Music]